hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about how to make it easier to
learn languages before the I do that
though I want to say thank you very much
to everyone who sent me birthday
greetings yesterday was my 74th birthday
I tried to reply to all the people on
Facebook and LinkedIn and messenger and
I don't know where they all come from
but hopefully I got everyone maybe I
didn't thank you very much and I want to
talk about a person called cat olam or
long Cato who was a Hungarian polyglot
very famous lady who lived in the 19th
and 20th centuries who mastered I don't
know 15 20 languages mostly through
reading on her own long before we had
all of the wonderful tools that are
available for us today and she had a
formula which I will show you now and
basically it said that the result or the
success in language learning depends on
the invested time which I would call
time spent with the language times
motivation all divided by inhibition and
I'm going to talk about that today and
how we can juice up that formula to our
advantage by finding ways to make it
easier to learn now first of all
language learning is about learning or
about acquisition it's not about
teaching you cannot teach someone who
isn't motivated doesn't spend the time
and feels a lot of inhibition and
frustration and resistance so in effect
whether you're in a school or whether
you're on your own you're still a
learner so that it's the learning you
know the factors that influence learning
that matter
affect the success of the teacher as
well as well the success of the learner
is the success of the teacher so first
of all motivation includes your interest
in the language the confidence that you
can succeed whether you like the way
you're learning all of these things
affect motivation the time is very
simple but it's time with the language
so time spent
reading in English about the language
sitting in a classroom where people are
speaking English to explain the language
that really doesn't count
it has to be time or at least it has to
be discounted what matters is the time
you spend with the language and then the
what katoa LOM refers to as inhibition I
would add the word resistance
frustration intimidation all of the
negative things that reduce the
effectiveness of what should be this
powerful motivation multiplied by time
that's gates basically enabling your
brain to learn so because motivation can
you know flag at times there's all kinds
of things can affect that can affect our
motivation motivation also affects the
time we have available because if we're
not very motivated we say we have no
time if we're very motivated we find
time so there's kind of an interaction
there also with the sort of divided by
the denominator the the sort of breaks
on our you know achievements in language
learning I think if you can find ways to
do things more easily that's gonna
increase your motivation that's gonna
make it more likely for you to spend
time and it's going to reduce the sort
of resistance so in my language learning
I look for things that make it easier
for me first of all my major learning
activity is listening because this thing
is easy to do I don't have to get up in
the morning and say I'm gonna study my
declension table alright
I'm gonna do drills to see if I remember
my case endings in Russian all of that
is negative builds up fear inhibition
frustration because we don't like to
make mistakes so I don't set myself up
to make mistakes I listen and as an
experienced language learner I am
comfortable with ambiguity with not
fully understanding therefore my
listening is enjoyable even if there are
parts that I don't understand now also
to make it easier I find
it very useful to use the listen to
course audio feature in Lync which I'll
show you how it looks here on the iPad
on the the browser version it's off to
the right of the screen you'll see a
little button there you click on it and
you get the full list of lessons in the
in the course so here for example on the
iPad and it would be the same in Android
or in an iOS you see the list of lessons
so that enables me to go in there I just
I just listen to course audio I take it
with me as I go off in the car and I
started wherever I want I can start it
at less than one or I can start it in
less than thirty and then it'll just
keep on going through the course I can
set it for shuffle or I can set it for
you know sequential listening very easy
I don't have to deliberately save things
to a playlist in order to have them
available for listening it's a little
thing but to me it's very powerful it
makes it easier another thing that I
find makes it easier and reduces the
resistance inhibition fear is the
ability to go through my lessons in
sentence mode particularly languages
that I don't know very well or in the
case of Persian where we don't have
text-to-speech it's just simply not
available so I go to sentence mode
sentence mode you'll see it in the
bottom right hand corner on your
portable device and it's the top left
hand corner in the browser version and
you'll see there's either one line or
lots of lines and you choose to read the
text either in the full text mode or in
sentence mode sentence mode has a big
advantage and that is that in most
languages it is time stamped to the
actual audio so in Persian where I don't
have text-to-speech I can try and read
it I'm still struggling to read Arabic
script and then work my way through it
trying to pronounce it correctly now I
can just hit the audio button and I will
hear that sentence just that sentence
and if I want to hear that sentence
again I hear
so this is something that makes it
easier for me I'm sure there are lots of
things in the different ways that we
learn that make it easier anything that
we do to make it easier to learn for
example in the sort of perennial debate
about whether we speak from day one or
don't speak from day one because
inhibition is is a break on our
motivation and on the time we're willing
to spend with the language the more I am
familiar with the language the more I
have listened the bigger my vocabulary
the less inhibited I am when it comes to
speaking so that's another reason why I
prefer to invest my time initially in
lots of listening and reading getting
used to the language building out
vocabulary so that when I go to speak I
am less inhibited I have reduced the
denominator there makes it easier for me
you know making it easier again finding
the time is a problem that's why
anything that takes the audio easily
over to a portable device so that you
can then find 10 minutes here or 20
minutes there you start to create habits
when you have habits that makes things
easier listening to voices that you like
makes it easier you're not inhibited
you're not put off by having to listen
to things that don't interest you or
where you don't like the voice so think
of that formula and the easier you make
things the more motivated your gonna be
the more you're gonna like the learning
process the more you're gonna spend time
and the less resistance there's going to
be so look at ways of increasing your
pleasure in learning the language look
at ways of making it easy easier for you
it shouldn't be hard work it shouldn't
be a struggle it should be as pleasant
an experience as possible and then
following columns formula you will learn
you will achieve a better result okay
then that's all for today bye for now
[Music]